sie zählen zu den wichtigsten und
einflussreichsten politischen theater
machen europas sie beschäftigen sich an
der grenze und zwischen der theorie der
wissenschaftlichen und der praxis sie
sind unglaublich viel beschäftigt einen
großen output was treibt sie um das zum
thema das thema unterschiedlich ich
denke was die themen ich habe das letzte
ihn auch überlegt was die themen
eigentlich verbindet ist das auch
beschäftigungen sind die mich schon
lange die mich schon lange an tragen und
die absurde weise obwohl es oft
politische themen sind universelle
themen irgendwo wurzel in meiner in
meiner eigenen biografie
also wenn wir das stück nehmen die
letzten tage der ceausescus war es
wirklich die fernseh erfahrung 19 89 der
erschießung dieses des ehepaars was mich
interessiert und ich hab das an
weihnachten gesehen als kind und so ist
es eigentlich überall bei heek habe ich
mich gefragt das ist die gleiche
generation wie ich war 17 als als dieser
genozid in ruanda 94 habe ich mich
gefragt was hat ja ich angetrieben und
als ich dann diese radiostation gefunden
habe gemerkt habe die firma die gleiche
musik wie ich habe ich etwas versucht
über diese über meine eigene generation
herauszufinden vielleicht auch über eine
eigene männlichkeit in gewisser hinsicht
und so ist es bei jedem projekt das ich
versuche eben im allgemeinen etwas
herauszufinden oft über mich oder über
die shows spielen die leute mit denen
ich zusammenarbeite und das interessant
dass sie dass sie sich quasi in den
eigenen prozess mit hineinwerfen hat man
den eindruck sie wirken unglaublich
ruhig und auch gesetzt wenn man sie
sieht und hört aber sie sprechen auch
immer wieder von von eigener angst und
eigener panik wenn sie ihre projekte
machen ja also es ist auch natürlich die
panik dass das machen was bzw dass das
so weil ich dass er gewissermaßen
moderiere der anleihe dass ich
vielleicht angst habe sagen wir bei den
moskauer prozessen da machen haben 50
leute mitgemacht die maus kam
die alle kein interesse hatten sich im
gleichen raum zu treffen
und da hatte ich einfach angst dass die
gewinne sich zerstreuung vor dass
stattgefunden hat in ruanda mit den
schauspielern hat sich denk ich mal ihre
angst auch nicht übertragen
gerade als wir woanders gespielt haben
das ist ja jedes wort das sie sagen
eigentlich per gesetz verboten und es
ist auch äußerst fragwürdig sich auch im
rahmen der kunst lustig zu machen über
eine million tote müssen sich
davonmachen im radio gibt es scherzte
sagen ich mal in dieser in dieser
inszenierung die ist ihr sehr sehr viel
spaß passiert und da machen die
schauspieler scherze über la reid über
über gruppen die sie dass sie selber
waren das sind oft kennen halten sich
was die legitimation und da wir ein
wenig panisch und versucht das natürlich
unten zu halten und das und das und das
dann auch durchzuziehen rebentisch sie
als philosophin mit schwerpunkt ästhetik
ethik politische philosophie die sich
mit der entgrenzung der kunst zu
intensiv auseinandersetzen
quasi aus der akademischen rate was
interessiert sie an mio eur naja wird es
mir verzeihen zunächst mal wählen unsere
jetzt hier kennen in der sendung nicht
die person sondern das werk und vor
allen dingen das künstlerische werk weil
ich finde dass wird wichtige fragen auf
über das verhältnis der gegenwartskunst
zur geschichte über das verhältnis von
kunst und politik natürlich und aber
auch über die globale bedingungen der
gegenwärtigen kunst welt das sind alles
wichtige dimension im werk von milo rau
und das interessiert mich
sie haben es schon erwähnt hate radio
dieses theaterprojekt dass sie über
diese ruandische radio station gemacht
hatten dass mit diesem teuflischen
cocktail aus pop und demagogie zu einem
massenmarkt quasi aufgerufen hat über
monate hinweg ein 1 1
eine welle der gewalt mit mit gepusht
hat und sie haben das in ein sogenanntes
rieneck mit überführt dass man das ein
bisschen versteht was das überhaupt ist
und wollen wir ganz kurz in dieses
filmdokument diesen film wenn sie
zusammen mit dem schweizer fernsehen
realisiert haben
reinschauen die kernidee miteinander
radius sein fahrgast in der animation er
ist radio herab
[Musik]
hier geht es dir heute an bord sind aber
debatte war durch mori matzerath die
heuer
nico josef resch
[Musik]
können sie uns ganz kurz das dispositiv
noch einmal erklären
ja also wie gesagt es ist ein remake mit
das heißt der versuch einer sendestunde
dieses radius das team in die
zwischenrunde ein mann eine sehr
wichtige rolle gespielt hat auf die
bühne zu bringen in eine glasbox die
zuschauer sitzen und darum und was in
dieser in dieser glasbox passiert
wirklich einer sendestunde und hier
kommen wir vielleicht ein bisschen in
die problematik des begriffs rieneck
hinein bereits war natürlich die serie
stunde so nie existiert hat es gab 18
moderatorin und nicht 4
ich habe also versucht das nach ersten
zeugenaussagen und auch das ding den
proben passiert sind diese stunde so zu
rekonstruieren dass sie symptomatisch
ist für dieses radio aber dass auch
übersetzt nach heute man muss sich
vorstellen ist radio brach in eine
mediale situation ein wo es nichts gab
kein fernsehen keine zeitung kein
anderes radio und da war es schon
unfassbar revolutionär wenn mal ein
popsong aus kinshasa gesenkt wurde
oder nirvana oder sowas und das muss
natürlich noch heute setzen das auch für
heutige zuschauer klar wird wie das war
also man muss das transponieren
und hier war für mich sehr wichtig und
ich denke das ist der andere wichtigen
moment ist dies positiv
also rieneck dann halte ich es einfach
genau nachmachen so das heißt auch eine
politische aussage machen eine
künstlerische aussage machen der leute
die es tun und hier waren es teilweise
sind die schauspieler überlebenden des
genozids in ruanda als ausgebildete
schauspieler natürlich als wanderer ist
auch fakt dass man den genozid überlebt
hat wenn man am leben ist natürlich
einen gewissen alter nicht zu vermeiden
aber trotzdem dass sich diese leute
diese künstler sagen ich tue das aus
trainer entgegen gründen bin ich in
diesem projekt dabei oder dann auch
nicht mehr dabei
das ist denkt der andere punkt dass
einerseits das ereignis andererseits die
frage was tut man wenn man es heute
wiederholt was geschieht dann das ist ja
auch sagen also diese verdichtung der
realität
mal gesagt haben als 1000 stunden radio
eine gemacht wurden liegt für sie die
die stärke die kraft des reckten
ich glaube das ist erstmal ganz sinnvoll
ist sich klar zu machen nicht das so
künstlerische adaption dieses zunächst
noch populären historistischen genres
des während man es erst seit 2000
wirklich diskutiert werden in der kunst
und man muss sich fragen was ist
eigentlich spezifik nicht des kunst
einsatz ist in diesem feld mein werk
maintals erstmal wieder aufführungen re
inszenierung historischer ereignisse hat
eine tradition die bis in die antike
zurück geht und sozusagen paradigmatisch
für das populäre daran waren so
bergmanns des amerikanischen
bürgerkriegs und sozusagen in dem
populären verständnis dieses genres wie
es eigentlich vorausgesetzt was die
bedeutung des historischen ereignisses
ist nicht und das wird dann sozusagen
wieder erlebbar gemacht durch die
wiederaufführung irgendwie so eine
unmittelbarkeit
jetzt habe ich den eindruck dass
eigentlich in künstlerischen adoptionen
diese chance was ganz anderes passiert
nämlich eigentlich dass es nicht darum
geht die vergangenheit zu behandeln als
etwas der bedeutung schon klar ist
sondern eigentlich das vergangene der
interpretation wieder zu öffnen
ja also das ist eigentlich um abgegolten
es geht nicht um etwas was noch der
interpretation und der
auseinandersetzung haare und jetzt kann
man sozusagen also ich würde jetzt ganz
grob in einer ersten annäherung ihre
arbeiten dort einsortieren das ist
eigentlich darum geht vergangenheit
interpretierbar erstmal wieder zu machen
also im grunde genommen ein moment
geradezu der unbestimmtheit dort
einzuführen ein moment des rätselhaft
werden zum historischen dokumenten auch
und da kann man jetzt glaube ich noch
mal die einzelnen arbeiten ein bisschen
auseinander
puzzeln ja also wenn man jetzt an dieser
arbeit die letzten tage der ceausescus
denkt dann ist es ja wenn ich das
richtig weiß nicht eine detailgetreue
rekonstruktion von chemischen eines
filmischen dokuments dass es über diesen
prozess gegeben hat was dann aber auf
die bühne transport transponiert wird
nicht also ich bin sozusagen durch den
medien wechseln
filmbühne aber auch durch den wechsel
dokument inszenierungen einen recht
hätte gesagt nicht hau effekt
verfremdungseffekte eingeführt der dann
auch formale details interessant werden
das glaube ich für ihre zuschauer nicht
also alles wird interessant nicht nur
wer sitzt der wie werden die blicke
getauscht sondern auch was ist was ist
das für eine atmosphäre der historische
index von allen dingen den kleidern der
ausstattung in dem prozess sei alles
wird so auffällig so einer anderen weise
das sozusagen es zur interpretation noch
mal ein date bei 1 hit radio ist es noch
mal anders nicht wie sie gesagt haben
da geht es also da ist sozusagen nicht
ein dokument vorlegen was man dann
sozusagen verfremdet durch den medien
wechsel sondern es ist auch dort das
spiel des massen von fakten und
fiktionen nicht hätte ich gerne ein hahn
also vielleicht wenn sie diese wieder
fünf mal wieder auf bearbeitung eines
historischen prozesses in der gegenwart
ihm die kontextualisierung einer
gegenwart ohne diese gegenwart quasi mit
dem mit dem zeigefinger einzubauen
da ist natürlich woanders interessant
und auch die frage nach der aktualität
oder der schweizerischen identität in
bezug zu verändert und dass wir die mich
interessieren das hat das mit uns heute
zu tun
also mich ist wie soll ich sagen ich
betrachte im grunde all diese diese
scheinbar exotischen vorfelder natürlich
als schweizer was mich interessiert hat
in dem speziellen genozid im speziellen
radio ist die bedeutsamkeit der
demokratie also dieses die gute sind die
mehrheit die tut sie sind die minderheit
und demokratie ist mit tirols und
deshalb muss die minderheit verschwinden
wenn sie nicht freiwillig sich
unterwirft
dann muss man resistenz machen und muss
gewissermaßen halt den krieg führen
das hat mich interessiert das ist ein
demokratischer argumentieren dagegen
dass ist müssen die dunkle seite der
demokratie könnte man sagen und das
kennt man als schweizer sehr gut das ist
mal die mehrheit
im endeffekt recht behält wie soll ich
sagen bei einer abstimmung aber ich habe
mal die tut sie mit den habsburgern und
die who tried genossen vergleichen ja
also das hat nicht dicht gemacht und das
war ist ein vergleich der schweizer
einfluss genutzt haben sie gesagt wir
sind den hutu ähnlich das sind auch
hirten wie die hilfe hitzer und die
these sind aristokraten gewissen die
habsburger und als er 1959 nach der
entkolonialisierung die tut sie
rausgeschmissen wurden war das ein
großer ich sage mal eine große
demokratische freude auch hinter schwarz
dass man gesagt hat okay jetzt ist jetzt
ist eine mehrheits herrschaft jetzt gibt
es auch die demokratie wie bei uns in in
afrika also in ruanda an und das ist ein
interessanter aspekt auch rtl also
dieses radio wurde eingeführt durch
entwicklungsgelder als das ist die erste
private stationen die nach der eröffnung
waren das nach nach 89 machten nach dem
fall des zwei blöcke systems eingeführt
wurde
es ist eine jugendstation und die leute
haben verstanden was da gesagt ob sie
haben gesagt na gut das ist demokratie
meint schon heute sollen sagen sie
wollen aber noch einmal nach was hier
enthalten das theater braucht ist das
theater das theater als großer
symbolischer raum und dieses diese
funktion mit der realität
das theater macht eigentlich zwei dinge
das theater vergegenwärtigt und das
theater schafft einen raum der ich sag
mal wo zuschauer und geschehenes
zusammen kommen und vielleicht die
dritte sache ist die jetzt brennt
projekt wie breiviks erklärung für mich
sehr wichtig war geschafft
bestimmte zusammenhang in der zeit und
eine bestimmte konzentration also jetzt
ganz statistisch gesagt kann ich im
theater leute zu wiegen sich ein
dokument 75 minuten lang anzuhören im
museum werden sie rausgehen im fernsehen
würden sie um schachten in der zeitung
wird einfach aber es ist eine andere es
ist eine andere art der konstruktion
klar aber das halten wir auch wiederum
heißen also mit welchen themen schafft
man es überhaupt diese aufmerksamkeit zu
generieren und dass man dran bleibt
wie sagt man dann klebt gerutscht ist
und schaffen ist er nur noch brisante
themen eben wie ruanda die chargers kurs
bewegte diesen diesen attentäter oder
bus um überhaupt noch institutionen und
zuschauer produktiv herauszufordern dass
sie dass sie dran bleiben ich meine ich
finde schon dass wir in einem moment der
kunstwelt leben wo es habe nicht mehr so
ist nicht dass das gegenüber so eine
bürgerliche lösung den formalismus ist
nicht er auf seine autonomie beharrt in
dem sinne dass die gesellschaft draußen
gehalten wird zu einem gegenteil muss
schon sagen die anrufung des politischen
ist der sozusagen das schmiermittel
überhaupt derzeit um die kunstwelt am
laufen zu haben nicht also jede biennale
überbietet sich wechselseitig an politik
anrufung und man muss sich natürlich
fragen so zu sagen welchen in welchen
sozialen moment taucht das eigentlich
auch nicht also ich finde da haben wir
auch die verantwortung tatsächlich
zurück zu treten und zu fragen was
trifft denn da auf einen andern ich habe
den eindruck es gibt also ein bisschen
so eine unheilige allianz mittlerweile
zwischen sozusagen so sehr kurz
gegriffen und verständnis der
künstlerischen arbeit gar nicht dass es
das ist das ziel der avantgarde sei sich
selber im leben aufzuheben auf der einen
seite und dieser neoliberalen impact
forderungen nach der sozusagen die kunst
und die geisteswissenschaften sozusagen
die aufgabe haben ihren unmittelbaren
einfluss in der gesellschaft zu beweisen
ja und das ist natürlich das ende der
kunst in gewisser weise insofern stellt
sich nicht nur die frage nicht an
welchen stellen kommt man mit welchen
themen rein sondern auch in welcher
weise macht sich doch auch die differenz
der kunst zur politik geltend und das
würde ich selbst in solchen arbeiten die
vorderhand gewissermaßen mit politischen
inhalten operieren wie ihre arbeit schon
auch verteidigen nicht dass es dann
nicht darum geht nicht schlicht darum
geht politische erkenntnisse zu gewinnen
vergeht das sozusagen journalistische
artikel könnte oder sollte tatsächlich
erst mal sozusagen material führende
auseinander
zum für unterschiedliche perspektiven
für ein diskurs gewissermaßen
bereitzustellen was was anderes ist also
sagen es geht so haben sie vorhin
gesprochen und nicht es geht darum
aussagen zu machen ich glaube das sagen
machen man in verschiedenen wehren
unbedingt aber noch immer quasi die
themenwahl also das heißt eben wichtige
brisante tabuthemen verdrängungs themen
die man braucht um überhaupt diese
aufmerksamkeit zu generieren und diese
konzentration die es braucht und dass
sie dann ein ganzes dispositiv ersetzen
das ist ja nicht nur dann quasi der
theater moment und es gibt
dokumentations- installationen auch dazu
bei gewissen arbeiten es gibt bücher
dazu es gibt jetzt viel mehr auch dazu
also wie bei hitradio dass die decken
das ganze spektrum also ich denke dass
das das politische ereignisse das
gesellschaftliche ereignis durch
irgendein alibi ist bei mir und mir ist
der spanische genozid ist ein alibi um
quasi das radio zu sprechen
ich denke das ist eine sehr wichtige
beobachtung gewesen bei den chargers
kuss habe ich im grunde das formale
experiment zu gemacht wenn was wäre ein
theater wo ein stuhl und ein mensch und
eine farbgebung die für mich
kommunistisch war als ich sie gesehen
habe im fernsehen gewisse brauntöne auf
der gleichen auf der gleichen ebene
angeordnet werden was ist das für ein
theater wenn ich dann zu wenn ich den
schauspiel- und sage nimmt die sätze
nicht auseinander und im video wird
ständig übereinander geschrieben was
befindet dazu führt letztlich ist man
gar nicht so steht aber dass man das
inszenieren das choreographie bei klar
aber das sind also dieses alibi ist
natürlich auch sowie mitunter zu seiner
eine eine marktsituation eines eines
regisseurs jemand der ein dispositiv
schafft und man hat ja auch schon
kritisiert dass sie quasi einen
amoralischen insektenforscher
glichkeiten also mit dem was sie was sie
wie sie
stage video konzipiert haben ja also ich
denke hier ist wie gesagt die
zusammenarbeit mit den mit den künstlern
den schauspielern extrem zu tragen also
ich denke ich würde einen amoralischen
insekten blick haben wenn ich leute
engagieren würde weil ich jetzt sage da
schaut das theater zürich arbeiten würde
und die würden dann einfach diese texte
sprechen
das wäre für mich also nicht amoralisch
aber es wäre illegitim und ich würde
mich auch fragen was das bringt das wäre
für mich kein mehrwert und wenn man zur
frage kommt was ist das politische im
theater so denke ich das theater einfach
einen politischen raum schaffen kann
aber nicht politisch ist in dem sinne
dass ich die aussage mache die weltwoche
ist gut gewählt welches vielleicht muss
uns zukommt und putin ist ein monster
sondern was hinten rauskommt beiden
projekten zum beispiel hier dass der
massenmörder ein land relativ erträgt
denn in moskau dass die argumente der
regierung der orthodoxen auch in ihrem
charisma auf eine unheimliche weise sehr
viel stärker in der serie als die
westlichen argumente der kunstfreiheit
das ist das was quasi die installation
ihrer totalität aus sagt gegen meinen
willen und und ich glaube da bin ich
tatsächlich gewisser hinsicht nicht
insekten veranstaltungen wirklich
tatsächlich moderator von etwas was
außer meiner macht steht und ich schaffe
eine experimenta situation oder ein
alibi in denen diese dinge für handelbar
werden in dieser in dieser alibi
es ist der tango parkett danach über das
theater als das geht dann in die
gesellschaft also ich meine ich finde
das schon
diese zwei punkte die so genannte haben
nicht einerseits die
aufmerksamkeitsökonomie das ist
sozusagen so klar als politisch
irgendwie markierte themen sind die
generell sozusagen gut laufen und der
weise wie man sozusagen mit dieser form
von institutionalisieren umgeht dass wir
schon eine wichtige frage also ich
glaube dass das theater da die
möglichkeit hat wirklich auf eine sache
sich zu konzentrieren anders als in der
bildenden kunst um unsere politische
themen chance hat wo man wo ich den
eindruck habe
da gibt es eben diese konzentration
nicht und da wären die themen so
aufeinander geschichtet dass es im
grunde genommen gegen die
aufmerksamkeitsökonomie läuft
ja also das tatsächlich die kritische
theorie hatte gesagt politik wird
veranstaltet nicht und finde gerade
nicht mehr statt
im theater glaube ich das hat eben
diesen konzentrations raum ist darauf
was mit dauerhaft ich also dauer und
zeit begonnen zu tun
da ist es anders aber ich finde deine
frage werde ich ganz gerne in stellen
jedoch weil ich mich dann schon frage
welche rolle spielt kontext in dem
ganzen nicht nicht hält radio ist ja
über 100 mal über 120 mal glaube ich
nicht aufgeführt worden
in unterschiedlichen ländern und eine
ethische frage natürlich die das stück
im verhältnis zu den zuschauern betrifft
ist immer die frage bekommt der
zuschauer sozusagen in diesem bild das
politisch und eigentlich auch ein ort
oder ist es sozusagen etwas was ganz
woanders spielt und was man dann ebenso
entgegennehmen kann nicht also das ja
auch eine wichtige frage und das ändert
sich ja je nach kontext wie sind ihre
erfahrungen gewesen
reagieren sie gewissermaßen auf diese
kontext wechsel auch noch mal ja
teilweise schon also wir haben also ist
beispielsweise avignon gespielt haben am
festival was so ein bisschen in
frankreich ein ganz wichtiger ort ist wo
es auch um die selbst repräsentation von
frankreich geht haben wir natürlich die
rolle von frankreich damit den text noch
mal umgeschrieben bei frankreich hatten
diesen genozid eine negative rolle
gespielt es ist fast ein bisschen ihr
genozid könnte man sagen aus dem
politisch gesehen da haben wir natürlich
das lob frankreichs in diesem sender
ständig gesungen wird noch verstärkt
wir haben dann sagen von mireille
mathieu beispielsweise nach dazugenommen
der tatsächlich gespielt wurde man kann
ihn ja neben oder nicht weil das
tausende von stunden gibt und der wurde
einmal gespielt
in ruanda war die situation natürlich
speziell also auch so dass wir wussten
dass es in gewisser hinsicht eine eine
politische geste ist weil die
erinnerungspolitik in ruanda eine der
pfeiler der momentan haben dass
diktaturen wird oder was auch immer ist
das eine ganz bestimmte weise erinnert
wird da musste man sich rückversichern
bevor uns dort aufgeführt hat und auch
bei den leuten bei den zuschauern
aus vorsicht heraus eine gewisse auswahl
machen dass man vor dem workshop machen
dann das aufhört was mich aber erstaunt
hat insgesamt desto man es in japan
zeigt oder den usa oder in deutschland
also in der schweiz eigentlich die
reaktion im doch sehr ähnlich sind sie
abhängig vom charakter der zuschauer
also sehr reines schockiert der andere
langweilt der dritte amüsiert dass es
das hängt sehr stark vom charakter und
erscheint vielleicht hat das mit der
globalisierung zu tun aber es scheint
eine tatsächlich globales verständnis zu
geben für kunst das gewachsen ist
vielleicht in den letzten 20 jahren ich
weiß es nicht
mich jedenfalls sehr sehr sehr erstaunt
als wir das in japan gezeigt haben dass
das komplett funktioniert hat dass es
keine verständnisfragen gab es in jeder
das sofort übersetzt hat in keine ahnung
die massaker der japanischen armee in
china beispielsweise also sofort
übersetzt hatten seien in seinen die in
der schweiz war die demokratie frage
wichtig in frankreich die rolle
frankreichs
und wo andere natürlich die eigenen
biografischen bringen wo einst jahr aber
auch ein problem sein so zu sagen das
sind alles immer zurück übersetzt das
dann sozusagen der gehalt auf so was
allgemein menschliches runter sind und
nicht ein bisschen der politisierenden
zog auch dadurch bekommen also auf die
sache was dann gemeinsam mit mannheimer
ist ja aber die dunkle seite der
menschen also das wäre ein bisschen
kunden aber diesen interpretationen zu
öffnen und sagen man stößt etwas an was
auch immer dann unter gesellschaft damit
mit diesem stein passiert das format
jetzt bei hitradio ist ist ja nicht das
gleiche wie bei den prozessen diese die
sie als kinect uns auch auf und und
inszenieren da würde mich interessieren
walter prozess an für sich ja so ein
eingängiges tool ist mittel ist
im theater die schauprozesse all diese
vielen gerichts dramen und manchmal ist
hier für mich ein bisschen die frage ist
manchmal die realität nicht noch besser
also noch intensiver als das theater mit
dem prozess um uli hoeneß nehmen
das ist dann wie schon fast bigger than
life das ist ja schon selbst kunst also
dass ich denke das ist richtig gerade
bei beispielsweise prozess mit ihnen
gegen bus bereit das ist auch der grund
warum meine prozesse
man kann sie gleich nach rieneck mit
denen aber einzelnes wiederaufnahmen
also ich führe die prozesse noch einmal
durch mit den beteiligten mit man von
einem ausgang mit offenem ausgang mit
einer jury nach gesetz der dauert dann
noch mehrere tage und da kommt eine
andere ein anderes urteil raus oder das
gleiche das hat es natürlich was in der
zeit passiert aber ich glaube die
wiederaufnahme eines schauprozesses
fousseray die zwei anderen prozessen ich
wieder verhandelt aber ein schauprozesse
der willicher quasi mit den schlechteren
mittel als ein statistischer
startversuchen theater zu machen
das würde wenig sinn machen bei den
chargers kuss war es noch mal eine
andere angelegenheit das war ein prozess
der gefilmt wurde
man sieht einen kleinen ausschnitt man
sieht darin aber nicht wer eigentlich
diesem rahmen setzen dass die heutige
legte rumänien
dieser film wurde versucht zu
unterdrücken er wurde dann etwas
irrtümlich doch gezeigt
es wurde aber nie ganz herausgefunden
wer wirklich alles drin sitzt und wenn
man das komplett zeigt mit bekannten
rumänischen schauspielern besetzt und im
nationaltheater in bukarest zeigt dann
passiert etwas politisches würde ich mal
sagen dass man plötzlich sagt wie viele
sind wir eigentlich weiter gekommen seid
neuen dach sind beispielsweise was ist
89 eigentlich passiert gab es ein elite
wechseln oder gab es den nicht als das
bewirkt dass kinect noch mal etwas
anderes vervollständigt in meinen augen
den prozess eigentlich während in den
moskauer präsidenten auch einen
gesellschaftlichen prozess mainz jetzt
ja es macht es macht etwas ich war es
macht gewissermaßen sündenbock vorgehen
sichtbar zum beispiel in rumänien einig
wie in ostdeutschland ist im grunde dass
das stasi oder dass die kult argument
natürlich das was ich mal hervorgeholt
im leben fertig machen will
das sieht man diesen prozess sehr schön
wie das läuft wie die politische klasse
eigentlich vorgeht
zwei leute umbringt und der rest bleibt
bestehen sind die engsten freunde von
treskow gewesen
ich meine ich muss ganz kurz natürlich
sagen dass die prozesse spektakulären
prozesse an denen wir sozusagen in den
medien teilhaben natürlich nicht kunst
sind nicht also sind jeden anderen logik
folgen und aus den arbeiten von milo rau
kann man natürlich nicht abziehen so
sehr dass sozusagen auch der grenze
marschiert zwischen kunst und
lebenskunst und prozess realität das ist
auch das moment ist als ob gibt das
theatrale und insofern ist die ganze
frage ist dann zu welche entscheidungen
wird wenn man kommen
es ist konvertibel schilder nicht
abzuziehen und dass das eröffnet
sozusagen eine andere eigene logik der
reflexion und der distanz name auch
fronten würde ich sagen von der logik
des entscheidens die man sich sozusagen
im echten leben aber sozusagen diese
distanz kann man sich da nicht leisten
also musst entscheidungen kommen damit
gerechtigkeit geben kann
in seinem kunstprojekten kann man
sozusagen von der logik des urteils ist
gar nicht so ein katalanischer punkte
noch mal zurücktreten und die logik des
urteils grund selber gewissermaßen auch
als problematisch in den blick nicht
sonderlich sagen also selbst bei solchen
arbeiten die vorderen sowie zusatz zum
echten prozess und so weiterlaufen würde
ich schon immer investieren das dann
noch mal was anderes ein was die
spezifik geradezu die autonomie der
kunst an diesen stellen ist weil sie
sich sozusagen in einer distanz setzt
zur logik des politischen zur logik des
juridischen die sie verhandelt und zwar
gerade die distanz kommt sozusagen
maximalen davos wo das gewicht von
juristischer politische entscheidung ins
spiel gebracht wird aber ins ernste
spiel das ästhetische aber ja das ist
dann schon nicht richtig also insofern
der bündnisfrage spektakulär vielleicht
aber
das nicht ist nicht kunst also ich
glaube das ist der entscheidende punkt
also ich glaube es war hegels drama oder
tragödien theorie da sagt das ist die
verhandlungen zwei gegensätzen die nicht
so einer entscheidung kommen können weil
sie einfach vollständig sind in ihrer
gegensätzlichkeit könnte man sagen und
und das sieht man in diesen als beispiel
einen prozess in russland die neue
orthodoxe seite gegen die globalisierung
gegen den westen und so weiter hat seine
berechtigung ist nicht komplett
konstruiert war so wie ich mir das
vielleicht als westlicher künstler
vorgestellt habe als ich zwei jahre lang
oder begonnen habe daran zu arbeiten
das werden wir dann rekonstruiert und
schluss wird das gute gewinnen es ist
überhaupt nicht so die gegensätze sind
am schluss noch absolut ware vorhanden
aber sie würden eigentlich durchgespielt
und ich habe dazu was zur rolle des
zuschauers bei den prozessen war eine
kritik es war wohl jemand geschrieben
hat es war das erste mal alle sich
gezwungen war nicht nur noch darum
sofort reingehen kann und rein grätschen
kann wirklich einfach insgesamt sechs
stunden lang stand von 15 zu hören die
ich überhaupt nicht vertreten den
zuzuhören und der geschieht innerlich
etwas dann antwortet man ja innerlich
beginnt die dinge abzuwägen und und das
war dass ich sagen ich war immer ein
bisserl ein kritiker des partizipativen
modells was im theater wahnsinnig
beliebt ist dass man durch räume geführt
wird und so weiter und teilnehmen muss
sondern ich wollte immer dass die rolle
des zuschauers wieder mal komplett ernst
genommen wir dass der zwang schweigen
verharren muss aber hat dieser gesamten
ist einmal die ganzen qualität dieser
situation ausgeliefert wird dieses clown
haften auch dass man dazu muss es
einfach nicht sagen kann stunden
natürlich eine aktivität hat nicht wenn
das ein punkt den der philosoph
hausherren macht nicht als diese ganzen
ideen dass man inzwischen unbedingt
aktivieren muss der mit politisch wird
dass da irgendwie was an unmittelbaren
mitmachen stattfinden muss dass das
unterschätzt nicht die aktivität des
interpretieren und der reflexion die man
sozusagen selbst im blick auf die
traditionelle cukas dennoch haben
aber ich glaube ja also wir werden noch
mal zurückkommen noch einmal was ich
ganz eingangs gesagt haben das bleibt im
kopf kostet das sie als der eigenen
biografie schöpfen und und diese themen
als alibi oder wie auch immer übernehmen
und wenn man sagt diese eigene biografie
geben die mit den chase co 89 war das 94
randa dass sie auch sagen so eine neue
feature generation quasi die man mich
braucht mobilisiert aktiviert hat die
verfügbarkeit dieser generation und das
seien eine art grunde nie ließ musk
analysiert werden dass die journalismus
dass sie versucht zu fragen immer damit
zu tun hat dass man auch nicht genau
weiß wo die macht liegt wer das system
ist wie es auf einen wirkt und das in
einem prozess der versuch gemacht wird
dieser diesem system eine form einer
gestalt zu geben
ja also um die frage des nihilismus
vielleicht kurz anzugehen in bezug auf
rottweil weil das war für mich der bezug
eine generation die komplett unpolitisch
ist dann wird dieses rassistische ding
tatsächlich hervorgeholt und dann wird
das zur jugendbewegung und dann gibt es
diesen massen lotte hat sich von männern
zwischen 17 und 25 also meinen damaligen
alter ausgeführt wird als als fahrer
untermalt von musik und man hat hier
alle elemente darin was man quasi
politische kunst was man ihr als als
äußeres nicht liste schon mehrdeutig
unterstellen können zum beispiel dieses
radio ist unabhängig ist politisches
gegen die regierung wird aber natürlich
von der regierung finanziert und es wird
ständig wird die regierung kritisiert in
diesem radio
also man hat fast müssen die handlung
tatsächlich des politischen künstlers
der kurs die institution die in
finanzieren kritisierten diese position
ausfüllt und dadurch also für mich ist
das nicht es muss eigentlich überhaupt
keine politische situation schafft
überhaupt keinen schafften den man
politisch range kann so ein anti ding
das man dann gegen die tutsi lenken kann
gegen die regierung gegen den westen
gegen die amerikaner aber es hätte alles
für mich straße hat gerade passt in dem
moment da passte gerade der massenmord
an einer bevölkerungs einen
bevölkerungsteile und das ist für mich
das biografische dass ich mich wie soll
ich sagen für mich war der weg zu einer
politischen haltung etwas was was lange
gedauert hat nach 89 20 jahre wo ich mir
plötzlich überlegt habe was ich
eigentlich wie ich agieren will also wie
ich wie ich nachdenke wird auf welche
weise in die ferne nicht vielleicht noch
links das war eine frage die nach 89
wieder ganz oft plötzlich und hier hat
meine situation 89 untergegangen letztes
aufblühen seines formats auch des
prozesses nicht mehr funktioniert und 94
dann bereits die globalisierte
gesellschaft ua diskurse vermischt
werden und die sind ja wahnsinnig links
diese diese moderatoren und sind
angekommen ist in der hand der
amerikaner und das ist eine
selbstbefragung im grunde meiner meiner
politischen betrieb natürlich das nicht
gefragt ich war krank die amerikaner ich
war auch und ich habe mich auch
schauspieler besetzt auch war um diese
dieses verhalten natürlich zu befragen
auf der bühne
und was würden sie jetzt sagen was
nehmen sie selbst aus diesem stück
heraus für sich selber
die erfahrung aus hate you ich liebe
viele erfahrungen als also das klingt
ein bisschen banal an aber viele als
regisseur heraus also wie man zb etwas
was dass es eine performance ist nicht
ein theaterstück gesagt mein text aber
wie meine performance leben 120 oder 150
mal wiederholen kann in verschiedenen
kontexten ohne dass es das es leer wird
und man eigentlich in dieser in dieser
maschinerie reinfeldt einfach die worte
zu wiederholen ohne sie ohne das zutun
damit zusammenhängt das war für mich
eigentlich gerade bei niedriger weil
diese diese fast schon ins absurde
grenzende herum touren des stücks in
context man sich gedacht hat jetzt
spielen jetzt auch noch in in siegen bei
köln
was würden wohl die siegener damit
anfangen dass man irgendwann dann dass
man lernt damit umzugehen auch
umbesetzungen auch kontext wechselt das
war für mich ein bisschen
die lehre aus man stellt sich vor nicht
dass das die zuschauer in ruanda
sehr viel klarer haben sagen wir mal
dieses moment der unzuverlässigkeit der
erinnerung der richtig gegenstand des
stücks auch ist nicht erinnerungen ist
er sozusagen hochgradig subjektiver
selektive und von situationen abhängige
akt und sozusagen hält video basiert ja
auch viel auf erinnerungen und es sind
ja richtig so momente eingebaut die gar
nicht stimmen können extra nicht aber
das da hat man zum beispiel eindruck
dass das publikum in ruanda natürlich
deutlicher sein muss also diese diese
diese stellen die gewissermaßen die
konstrukt heftigkeit auch der erinnerung
und der geschichtsschreibung hervorheben
dass das erbe und die fatalität dass ich
habe einen satz ich war in ruanda als
der uno bericht heraus kam dass die
ruandische armee beim kampf gegen die
milizen immer aus kongo also die jetzige
man könnte es vielleicht an genug sie
nennen und so weiter und das war ein
skandal in ruanda und dann hat der
iranische generalstabschef zu einer zu
einer pressekonferenz gerufen und dort
hat er gesagt es sind absurde
anschuldigung als neben allen anderen
argument nicht ich bin der meinung dass
die nicht stimmen nebenbei bemerkt aber
er hat den satz gesagt das sind absurde
anschuldigungen wir sind moderne armee
würden wir das tun wenn du nicht
nachtreten nutzen sollen moderne waffen
und das ist ein satz der oder 2010
gesagt und ich habe ihn dann in hektar
übernommen weil er hätte auch 2009 10 94
gesagt werden können und das war für
mich ein bisschen eine ich sagen ein
hinweis auf den auf dem sagen wir mal
die qualität oder den fatalismus auch
ein bisschen der geschichte natürlich
ist dieser genozid nicht abgeschlossen
jetzt die sprechen nicht über etwas
historisches entsprechender über jetzt
eben über die art wie wir es jetzt
erinnern und wie jetzt das ein
politisches oder ein emotionales tool
nach wie vor ist und
was ihn so anders wenn man sich jetzt
vorstellt ja 94 der lange lange
schmerzvolle prozess auch eine versuchs
der aussöhnung oder diese verdrängung zu
bewältigen ist ist in ruanda etwas
passiert hatten sie das gefühl als sie
da war mit mit mit dem stück mit den
teilnehmer mit den zuschauern auf jeden
fall man muss sagen dass die ruander
gegebene situation also dass die mörder
eigentlich zurückgeholt wurden von
regierung aus den früchten klagen wieder
angesiedelt worden dass mörder und
überlebende nebeneinander wohnen dass
die ruanda
die großmeister der erinnerungspolitik
und gleichzeitig in gewisser hinsicht
auf drängen sind und dass sie sehr sehr
viel ertragen also dass wir schnell auch
passiert das in deutschland nach dem
krieg zum beispiel also die kunst in
ruanda begann sich ganz schnell ganz
bewusst das ging nicht 20 jahre wird
bereist und ging sofort los eigentlich
auch modellhaft los mit der
beschäftigung es gibt eine erinnerungs
woche die am 6 april beginnt ist 13
also es gibt da eine ganz ein
professionelles umgehen und trotzdem hat
dieses stück als aufgeführt wurde in
dieser in dieser in dieser kalt haid wir
haben noch videos fahren und in ruanda
nicht gezeigt das hätte keinen sinn
gemacht dass zur armen und zu erklären
und in dieser härte als wir im studio in
ruanda im ehemaligen studio wieder
gespielt haben
der biber tisch den leuten einfach mal
eine stunde lang die spucke weg bevor es
dann wie man dazu nennt eine
publikumsdiskussion gab und ich erinnere
mich gut dann die frau das ist eine eine
tussi die frau des jetzigen senats light
assist leiters des senats das ist ein
hut also es gibt die kirchen eine starke
versucht das auch wieder tatsächlich
durch mischen oder wie man es nennen
will und dass ich gesagt habe versichert
der schrecklichste gewesen diese lieder
zu hören die musik quasi hat ihre cds
tatsächlich nach dem genozid einfach
weggeschmissen
also diese ganze pop schiene nicht mehr
ertragen konnte weil die derart
missbrauchen
und das fand ich ein beunruhigendes
detail
ich meine das ist ja auch in der ganzen
frage nicht wie geht man eigentlich um
rechtlich wie schafft man das überhaupt
dass das zu bewältigen also die ganze
frage wie strafrecht und die gaca also
das halbfinale sagt ein mix gibt es ja
auch stimmen die sagen es ist wichtig
dass diese prozesse stattfinden fast
wichtiger gewissermaßen als die
ergebnisse sind also das ist dass das
bühnen sind auf den es
auseinandersetzungen geben kann wo auf
den gestritten werden kann über den
hergang der ereignisse und so weiter
insofern sind ist das ein wichtiger aber
sie haben jetzt bühne gesagt also das
sind dort gerichte die weil die das
normale juristische system hunderte von
jahren hätte um das öffentliche
aufzuarbeiten ja genau aber das heißt
die grenze und das wäre vielleicht so um
dass nochmals auszuweiten also zu
vergrößern und zu absolvieren was ihm
bisher besprochen haben also die grenzen
der kunst die grenze zwischen realität
und kunst kann man kann man das
überhaupt schön sauber voneinander
trennen
so wie sie das vorher klar apodiktisch
gesagt haben der prozess mit uli hoeneß
ist kein theater wir versagen ist ein
spektakel nicht dass auch ein theater
nahe begriff und ich würde das übrigens
auch für sozusagen funktionierende
demokratien immer verteidigen das ist
das geben muss das so anders als viele
leute die meinen das sei gewissermaßen
die entfremdung entfremdet zustand der
demokratien wenn sie blicken auf
wahlkämpfe und und diese sozusagen
öffentlichen gefechte ich bin der
meinung das ist ein konstitutiver
bestandteil demokratischen lebens das
ist das geben kann das konflikt auch
gewissermaßen auf öffentliche grünen
wenn man so will kommt und dass der
ausgetragen wird
aber ich würde eben sagen die differenz
nicht zwischen kunst und leben kunst und
politik läuft heute nicht mehr so dass
man sozusagen irgendwie die zone der
freiheit hat die von all dem nicht
probiert des untergrunds offensichtlich
nicht sondern eigentlich das habe ich
versucht zuvor hin zu sagen ich ist es
ein shift im verständnis dieser
ästhetischen differenz nämlich dass es
ein anderer modus der erfahrung ist in
der wir da eintreten im ästhetischen der
sich eben unterscheidet zu den
erfahrungen die wir mit theoretischen
texten machen oder auf der straße und in
der politik aber das sagt natürlich
zugleich auch dass ich dann kein problem
damit zu sagen
auf der politischen seite gibt es auch
etwas wie inszenierung unserer alters
folgt aber trotzdem einer anderen logik
und das sagt nicht positiv gemeint diese
inszenierung genau
und da gibt aber trotzdem in beiden
fällen unter umständen grenzen
sie haben das auch erwähnt ein beispiel
schon wieder zu ihm zurückzukommen und
andere anders breivik ist dieser
rechtsradikale terrorist sie haben seine
verteidigungsrede die wenn ich mich
richtig erinnere nicht öffentlich
ausgestrahlt oder gedruckt wurde haben
sie von einer deutsch-türkischen
schauspielerin lesen lassen und ist hier
nicht eine grenze überschritten quasi
dass man den gedanken eines
massenmörders ein solches podium ein
spektakel nachgeliefert ja also wir
haben sie jetzt vor drei tagen in
brüssel gemacht worden dass zuerst ein
parlament macht im eu-parlament das hat
man wie meistens in den war das spiel
das stück nicht geklappt und dann haben
wir es in einer paprika gemacht dass an
diesem großen platz im zentrum wo die
bürger sich 34
wie soll ich sagen das bürgermeisteramt
und das ist für mich wie konstitutiv
dass man für dieses stück ist speziell
dass man kontext welt wo man sagt was
für ein podium ist das eigentlich es ist
1 1 ein politisches problem es ist eine
antwort möglich ist 1 wo man auf eine
bestimmte weise zu hören dass ich finde
es schwierig wenn man jetzt eine
was ich ein bisschen albern auch
veränderte eine ästhetisierung dieses
tags das machen würde was man würde ihn
rein ästhetisch haben und dann würde man
ins theater gehen dann wird es da
irgendwie schiller die räuber und bleibt
meine erklärung geben
man kann sich für einen der abend
entscheiden das für komische uns in
diesem kontext einführt komisch wenn ich
es eigentlich auch wenn es wie gesagt
wir haben das immer mehr private folgen
lassen ist die möglichkeit nicht geben
würde was aber für mich das interessante
einem text war war eigentlich dass er
von breivik ist dass du aber
interessanterweise geht der 75 minuten
man kennt eigentlich nur schnitzel von
brig west auf seine frau ist oder sie
ausstreckt dann dass die kinder
umgebracht hat und so weiter weil man in
75 minuten zuhört vergisst man nach
würde ich behaupten spätestens zehn
minuten dass es bei big man vergisst es
wirklich und weiß es nicht mehr
es ist ganz seltsam anhört plötzlich ein
text der derart banale ist direkt op
pace die rad wieder alles zusammenfasst
was man vor allem als schweizer
ständigen den abstimmenden hört also
nicht mehr als terroristische text
interessant ist sondern als ideologie
aus europa aus unserer zeit die absolut
mehrheitsfähig ist und das hat mich
interessiert deshalb keine
psychologisierung keine mimikry kein
kein versuch das zu ste sie und in der
inszenierung sorgen
da kann man es noch mal ganz gut dran
erklärt nicht also diese differenz also
es ist sozusagen material aus der
realität nicht ein dokument an dass man
schon rankommen kann dass man sich
ansehen kann und was das finde ich
interessant nicht dass der gegenstand
der arbeiten der kunst in dem fall von
milo rau oftmals ist nicht nicht die
realität selber das war sozusagen die
idee des realismus früher nicht also man
dann sozusagen die realität selber zum
material beschafft sozusagen erkenntnis
bild was hier sozusagen gegenstand ist
sind dokumente sind bereits durch
sprache durch bilder erschlossene
möglichkeiten und das ist wie so ein
second ort realismus der darauf seite
der uns gewissermaßen diese erschließung
noch
ansehen lässt in ihrer in ihrer logik
aber gleichzeitig muss ich auch sagen
natürlich stellt sich diese ethische
frage nicht welches material nach der
grenze unter wird man überhaupt dieser
logik der kunst die eben eine logik des
unbestimmt machen es auch ist nicht man
vergisst und das von breivik ist man
vergisst es ist ein gewisser weise den
kontext und sieht andere dinge andere
dinge scheinen auf und es kann ja sein
nicht das material gibt oder zeiten gibt
in denen es nicht angemessen ist aus
diversen gründen aus ethischen gründen
politischen gründen bestimmtes material
dieser dieses dialog des umgestimmt
machens des bestimmten zu unterwerfen
diese übersetzung von realitätssinn
kunst ist ja auch im zusammenhang mit
bleidick interessant weil es ja jetzt
auch eine debatte gibt über ein gedenken
memorial auf dieser insel wo das
passiert ist und dass der künstler diese
insel zwei schneiden möchte mit einem
kanal und eine aussichtskanzel die dann
auf eine wand den blick freigibt oder
die namen der opfer geschrieben werden
dass die familien sich wie immer hinter
gegen ein schreiben dass sie die namen
ihrer kinder missbraucht werden quasi
für eine künstlerische intervention also
das heißt dass man auch eine
verantwortung hat quasi weil man aus der
realität schöpft dass man dinge ins
rollen bewegt die man ja diese geister
die man sich gar nicht mehr
kontrollieren kann
wenn sie fiktional sind wenn sie sagen
jeder zusammenhang mit der realität ist
reiner zufall
hollywood film am anfang dann dann
sollen sie ja auch gewissermaßen einen
gewissen teil des publikums das nicht
freiwillig teil eines künstlerischen
produktes ist
ja also ich glaube da also das ist der
unterschied zwischen wie auch immer
realistischer kunst und und und rein
fiktional kunden wie die für mich schon
verhältnisse auch sind da wenn man hat
uns natürlich bei realistische kunst
immer mit etwas realem zu tun was dann
auch reale konsequenzen im ethischen
sinn eigentlich natürlich hat das sind
leute von preisig umgebracht worden
das ist ein fakt den kann man nicht den
kann man niemals weg schaffen das wird
immer ein teil bleiben was der auch sagt
auch wenn einen roman über grün ein
comic zeichnet damit sie wieder comic
von breivik sein dass er dahinter die
toten stehen ich habe mich wirklich bei
breivik bei dem beide ins team habe ich
mich gefragt und wissen an geschäft von
caracas hin nur experiment wo die posen
rede von himmler verlesen lässt habe ich
mich gefragt ist es möglich eine
konzentration auf etwas herzustellen was
im medialen spektakel total
untergegangen ist im ist wahnsinnig er
ist ein massenmörder und so weiter was
sind diese argumente mit denen man
mehrheiten hat zu denen sich preisig
bekennt dass er für mich war der grund
warum ich das inszeniert habe dass
breivik nach einer halben seite sagt und
jetzt wollte ich an die schweiz erinnern
die haben die minarett-initiative
durchgebracht so hat die karriere waren
nicht aber ich finde das super das ist
gemacht haben wie finde ich ist es so
etwas wie wir sie zu radikal
ich finde es aber toll und dachte
irgendwas was ist das eigentlich für ein
diskurs den er da hat und wie kann ich
den wie kann ich den zur ausstellung
bringen im grunde und das war für mich
die frage ich habe also tatsächlich habe
ich bei den opferverbänden
ich habe mir diese indische fragliche
auch geständig angestiftet von vielen
leuten und haben nachgefragt was sie
davon halten wenn wir das machen
und die haben uns jetzt auch nach oslo
eingeladen das ist auch zeigen also es
ist soll ich sagen
die gleiche frage was passiert wenn die
wenn die opfer das sehen die opfer des
spielen dass ich kann es nicht
entscheide ich
es ist einer australischen diesen
vereinen drohende frage der autorschaft
ist natürlich da auch nicht ganz
relevant drin nicht
so hat man sozusagen erstmal position zu
tun die bestimmte missstände ausstellt
ohne politische kunst zu machen und am
ende sozusagen das was das einzige wir
sozusagen was relevant bleibt ist der
name des künstlers als regisseurs oder
hat man sozusagen prozess in denen
qualität bearbeitet weil es etwas
anderes mit dem angestoßen werden wenn
man den bates schließende das werden sie
von angst und panik sprechen im rahmen
ihrer projekte dass das schon auch damit
zu tun hat ja fast ausschließlich
eigentlich also wie gesagt ich arbeite
als der kollektiv behilflich bei mir
wirklich wichtig weil ich arbeite nur
mit künstlern die vielleicht nicht mal
auf der atem hören sondern ein gewisser
hinsicht mehr ist über die dinge über
die wir sprechen sehr viel mehr wissen
sie bescheid wissen und ich nicht
und da bin ich natürlich auch natürlich
panisch ganz einfach weil ich dann denke
was passiert was passiert jetzt kann
nicht quasi das dass das noch in der
luft behalten und so zum schluss ganz
kurz verregnet ist als fazit was kann
kunst nicht gerade die kann uns fehlen
nicht
er ist eben kein juristischer prozess
kommt nicht zu solchen entscheidungen
die notwendig sind sie es nicht politik
unmittelbar vielleicht lass ich es dabei
also kunst ist da ich sozusagen die
autonomie der kunst verteidige und finde
dass eine spezifische reflexive
vergegenwärtigung slowik hat darin kann
sie viel aber dann hat sie auch grenzen
und ich glaube die konz tritt sozusagen
in ihrem eigenen in ihrer eigenen logik
in ihrem eigenen potenzial neben die
politik und nehmen die theorie der kunst
kann mich ganz für nichts kann nicht
über leben und tod entscheiden also sie
kann sehr viel weniger als der
allerkleinste herrscht immer noch
einzeln werden und das ist das also aber
ich denke tatsächlich dass oft kunst
können einen kontext ändern kann noch
mal neu nachdenken lassen über etwas was
scheinbar abgeschlossen scheint und so
weiter
das kann kunst was beispielsweise wie
soll ich sagen also beispiel das segment
ist niemanden gegeben
das kann nur die kunst und das ist
angeboren sein leben hieß herr wolf dank
für das gespräch
[Musik]